en un día en el que las armas debían
permanecer en silencio y los cielos
libres de bombardeos columnas de humo
llenan el cielo de jartum la capital de
Sudán una señal de que las facciones se
enfrentadas siguen incumpliendo la
extensión del alto el fuego que ambas
habían acordado el jueves los combates
continúan también en la ciudad de la más
grande del país los paramilitares de las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido acusan al
ejército de violar La tregua con ataques
aéreos contra sus bases sin embargo el
ejército dice que son los paramilitares
que no respetan el alto del fuego en
este hospital de ondurman el personal ya
no puede hacer frente ante la afluencia
de pacientes hay una enorme carencia de
equipos médicos y una carencia en las
instalaciones del hospital la situación
es tan difícil que los voluntarios
intentan llevar la situación como pueden
porque es el único hospital que sigue
funcionando la violenta lucha por el
poder a desencadenado una crisis
humanitaria decenas de miles de personas
han huido en la ciudad las colas para
subir a un barco de evacuación son
interminables estuvo entre las personas
atrapadas durante casi siete días sin
comida bebida electricidad y agua las
condiciones eran muy malas pero gracias
a Dios conseguimos salir y venir aquí a
por Sudán también continúa la evacuación
de ciudadanos extranjeros medios de
comunicación estadounidenses afirman que
un convoy de autobuses con 300
estadounidenses
Reino Unido dice que su operación de
rescate terminará el sábado tras haber
disminuir la demanda del número de sus
ciudadanos que quieren salir del país